you know it's a real shame that this
movie got pushed back so much if it had
come out in 2010
it may have just gotten an Oscar nod
Nicolas Cage in generic the movie
otherwise known as season of the witch
now this is movie 101 when a movie's
release date keeps getting pushed back
it's a pretty good sign that the movies
gonna be absolute doesn't always
happen that way there are exceptions but
it's pretty good rule of thumb so enter
generic the movie Nicolas Cage and Ron
Perlman play a couple of X nights from
the Crusades who are charged with taking
this pretty hot chick who might just be
a witch across a generic happy meal cut
out of Azeroth to get to this town so
this girl can stand trial and
accompanied by a fellowship of no I
mean a party we have an adventure in
which a logic and plot holes in sue but
first let's get to that oscar-worthy
acting the best parts actually Hellboy
the worst part it's a lot of everything
else there were a lot of cheesy ass
lines in this movie it looks like the
movie was filmed and they filmed these
cheesy little lines just to throw in
there to bring some light heartedness to
the movie which it being delayed for so
long wouldn't doubt it Nicolas Cage kind
of tries out the Kevin Costner Robin
Hood thing he kind of has an accent
earlier on in the movie in like two
scenes and his brain was just like dude
come on let's just try to get to the
other side of this river of with
some dignity just come on just lose the
axe I'm doing these like alright
whatever is gone and other things happen
in this movie that don't make sense like
this dude was mauled by a wolf like
right here in his face and he s like
three scratches right there and that's
it have you ever known a person to come
out of a wolf mauling looking so good no
it never happens like that it was look
like that one chick you know the chick
with a monkey ripped her face off
is not pretty three scratches he's good
and a little-known fact about the Black
Plague which plays a part in this movie
and it's everywhere in the later stages
of the plague it's really contagious
in which case most of the cast probably
should have died out an hour one of this
movie and then at the end of the movie
and there are some mild spoilers right
here just mild those it doesn't matter
they all have to throw down with Goliath
from gargoyles and then the movie
becomes generic the CGI adventure
it's just CGI and then more CGI I mean I
would rather have this ultimate evil
that's like devil who looks like a dude
I mean that's okay let's go that route
but no movies always want the huge juicy
gie evil dude from Fantasia now I was
really lenient on Nicholas Cage for
Sorcerer's Apprentice but not this time
now for Night on Bald Mountain that's
asking too much this movie is in fact
generic dog the CGI adventure and
in the end of this movie after the whole
movie wraps up you actually think about
the plot and what happened and when and
why and you actually come to the
conclusion that the movie didn't need to
happen you're like wait a minute why'd
they do that they didn't need to do that
they the movie did not need to happen
what a way to kick off 2011 yeah but if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more than click right here
to see more